it is great to welcome to the program
today Yaron Brook and Rob Larson Iran
has joined us before and his chairman of
the ein Rand Institute host of the Iran
Brooks show on YouTube Rob also a
returning guest Rob Larson is economics
professor and author of bit tyrants and
capitalism versus freedom and indeed
today we will be talking about liberty
and freedom relevant always but
particularly right now what is the
system of freedom and liberty is it
capitalism or is it socialism and to get
us started let's go to Rob Rob give us
give us a sense of your perspective on
which system is the system of freedom
and and maybe a little bit about why
yeah thanks David
so it's great to be talking about
freedom here today and I think it's
always good to start just to think about
the value of freedom of course to each
of us so I always tell people the value
of freedom is whatever it is you like to
do with your time and your limited human
lifespan you know so whether you're
individually into playing the guitar or
Pokemon collecting or Star Trek themed
cosplay events whatever it might be
that's the value of freedom to you so
what can we say about it well there's a
number of traditions here in different
views one thing the philosophers have
done historically is to sort of take the
idea of freedom or Liberty and divide it
into sort of two separate domains
broadly speaking so one version of that
would be negative freedom which we
usually refer to as meaning an
individual being free from outside
coercion by some sort of institution or
outside power so when you're free to
choose your career and no one dictated
to you what you have to do with your
life we call that negative freedom or
your freedom from outside coercion we
sometimes say alternatively figures like
Isaiah Berlin and some others have found
use in elaborating on a concept of
positive freedom or positive Liberty or
rights where we look at more what you're
free to do and how much you're able to
enjoy or take advantage of opportunities
they're available to you so are you free
to do
something like consume healthcare that
the economy produces or something like
that and of course there's divergent
views about that I'm sure your own will
want to address that too but these sort
of traditional picture is when we look
at economic systems if we look at for
example capitalism system broadly
characterized by markets and private
ownership of most property the
traditional view is that capitalism
provides that negative freedom because
you're free to choose what products you
want to consume or your career and so on
and no one dictates that to you okay and
on the other hand it doesn't provide
positive freedom of course capitalism
doesn't come with a right to or freedom
to consume healthcare or housing or
something like that but in my books in
my work you know I'll kind of give away
the the big message you know so trigger
warning parents caution spoiler alert I
argue that modern capitalism doesn't
really provide either of these forms of
freedom we agree on the positive freedom
part but that negative freedom I would
suggest gets impinged pretty frequently
by the level of concentration that big
firms have in some markets and the
strong concentration of wealth that we
see historically into what amounts to a
sort of upper class within capitalism
and you could argue that their major
decisions that change our lives and in
some cases control markets could be a
violation of our negative freedom from
outside powers acting upon us you know
now of course the alternative system
could be a form of socialism and again
we try to be specific when we talk about
this stuff as much as we can so
socialism is traditionally it's worker
control of the means of production in
some form so you go to work and you and
your co-workers have access to the
information that management today has
about the conditions the firm is facing
and you work together with your
co-workers to decide what will happen
and you send representatives to meet
with the other industries that you
articulate with and you manage
production with our big economic units
of today which we need to efficiently
produce the goods and services we all
rely on we can manage that anymore
as it were a democratic workplace based
fashion rather than having large firms
and powerful individuals being in charge
of it and again there's a lot to say
about this and many people will suggest
that socialism means you govern
control over every part of your life but
one thing I'd like to turn to is you
know if we look at the idea of
totalitarianism and thought control
things that people naturally fear from
authoritarian institutions the
definitive english-language writer on
those subjects is George Orwell you know
and George Orwell famously wrote the
road to leak appeared in some other
places that capitalism makes freedom
impossible as he put it and the only
thing for which we can combine is the
underlying ideal of socialism justice
and liberty so there's some different
ways to chop up the subject so Iran
we've heard from Rob a couple of things
we've heard him first address why he
does not believe that capitalism is a
system of freedom and liberty
but we've also heard him assert that at
least in some forms socialism can be
that system so let me turn it over to
you so you can kind of introduce us to
your perspective sure so obviously I
disagree with almost everything Bob said
is at least his introduction of freedom
you know kind of positioned it I think
some properly historically you know
freedom is and and and we can think of
this as what what what did immigrants
the in the 19th century coming to
America think when they were coming to
the land of the free when they were
motivated by fear what are immigrants
today coming to the US and immigrants
still come to the u.s. think when they
come here they're going you know they
want more freedom what does that mean to
them and I think overwhelmingly what
that means to them is that they get to
choose their path in life that they may
get to make decisions about career about
you know about consumption about where
to live how to live it is the freedom to
pursue your values that or the ability
to pursue your values free of coercion
free of authority free of violence free
of somebody dictating to you what you
can and cannot do
so it's both positive and negative right
it is the freedom from coercion it is
the absence of coercion that makes it
possible for you to go out and pursue
your values
capitalism by definition is the system
of freedom from coercion capitalism in
my in my mind capitalism is that system
in which the government does one thing
and one thing only
it frees us from coercion it does not
cause it does not allow us to cause each
other to use force against one another
it catches the crooks and the criminals
and the robbers and the thieves us on
and puts them away and as a consequence
it really is the only system in human
history that is allowed for real freedom
the freedom individuals to pursue their
own life free of of the fear of being
cursed be a you know of I mean there's
obviously always some criminals in a
society so fear isn't zero but but free
that but but can you know confident that
there is an entity that is protecting
them and that is the government and
that's the only role in my view of the
government whereas socialism is the
example exactly socialism the end is the
system of coercion and I my guesses of
the three of us I'm the only one who's
actually lived in a socialist country a
socialist country that actually had the
labor union was the largest employer in
the country so it wasn't the state it
was the labor union and it was they
actually did it owned the means of
production they owned all of that and I
can tell you it sucked the technical
term is it was poor it was inefficient
it was unproductive it did very very
badly economically I mean I mean you're
on not to interrupt for people who don't
know and maybe Bob doesn't know can you
say where that was and what the
circumstances were I was born and raised
in Israel and Israel was was a was
basically founded as a socialist country
by committed socialist and until I'd say
the early 1980s the largest employer in
the country and the largest owner of the
means of production was the labor union
the labor union Israel if that this
change that Israel's become quite a bit
richer as it has become quite a bit more
a capitalist not anyway close to the way
I would like it but you know I'll give
you an example I mean and the capital
if you want to be a socialist nobody is
going to stop you because they're not
gonna curse you then I can have place
barriers honey if you want to go and
start a communal farm a communal factory
a workers entity anything like that you
can do it you know I think you'll fail I
think you'll be miserable I think it's
it's horrible but you can do it right
and the socialism I can't do what I'm
doing right now I love finance I run a
hedge fund kind of in addition
everything else that could new it
couldn't start it would be illegal to
start it I couldn't have an
employer-employee type of business to
try to compete with the owner controlled
businesses out there I would actually go
to jail I guess if I if I competed with
those I think in in socialism socialism
by definition constricts and restrains
opportunity and therefore restrains and
constricts individual choice and has no
respect for what people produce that is
for private property okay so so far the
conversation has I think rightly focused
mostly on the theoretical although Euron
did introduce the this example of Israel
where he where he was lived at an
earlier point in his life maybe now to
go back to rob you could tell us some of
the ways today examples today in 2020
where you find that capitalism actually
restricts freedom and we could use that
as a jumping off point to go back to
Iran right on for sure so traditionally
when we look at that negative conception
of freedom we mentioned earlier in which
Iran agreed with the idea there is we
want to maximize people's realm of
personal liberty by limiting how much
other institutions can control you and
dictate to you and push you around it so
manner I think that's fine I think the
issue here is not recognizing how common
those things are in today's modern
large-scale commercial capitalism where
we do kind of encounter this stuff
pretty frequently so an example that's
relevant to my recent work on the tech
industry and what bit tyrants we look a
lot that's just some basic market
economic phenomenon you know we make a
huge variety of different goods and
services in any economic system the
services and goods are different so why
would the markets be identical
and one thing we see in some markets is
what we call network effects especially
in tech relevant markets today so some
folks may know network effects apply in
certain markets where the value of a
good increases as more people use it
which can seem kind of strange but if
you think like consider your telephone
right if you're the first person with
the telephone great call yourself rates
are pretty handy as soon as some other
people get on the phone line now it has
some value to you because you can be
shouting me communicate with other
parties and so even today when kids
reach 14 or however old they are and
their parents get them their first
smartphone that does slightly increase
the value of the phone in your pocket
that's one more party you might
potentially be able to reach and we call
this a network effect when we have this
strange sort of pattern because of the
nature of that market well the thing
about network effects they have a number
of ramifications for how they shape
markets one pretty dramatic one is
there's a need for the technical
standards so if our phones all work in
completely different ways they won't be
able to interface and we won't be able
to communicate with one another but this
applies to any kind of good that's
mediated through networks so computer
operating systems applications online
search they all have this network effect
associated with them and look I go into
a lot of detail about the different ways
they come up we tend to see is a
unusually strong tendency just as an
example for monopolization in markets
where you end up with one extremely
dominant firm because it attracts so
many users that when people want to do
computing they look at the option that
has the most users you know so Facebook
is the clearest case you know what are
you gonna join when you're a young
person and network that has none of your
friends on it or the one that has almost
all human beings on it it's a relatively
clear choice just the nature those
incentives are such the early incumbents
in these markets and there's lots of
little wrinkles in details but the
pattern is for the early incumbents of
these markets to develop runaway leads
and to become but not well this or maybe
a sort of an oligopoly situation where
you have a small number of extraordinary
early large firms so an example of that
might be smartphone operating systems
like Google's Android
in Apple's iOS we tend to see is that
what's firms have these huge
monopolistic market positions regardless
of exactly how they acquire them they
have tremendous power over what happens
in those markets and a lot of influence
over us too you know
when I update my phone software it's
rare that I read the full entirety Terms
of Service Agreement that accompanies it
cuz it's so damn long and it's filled
with baffling technical legalese you'll
only understand some of it and we're all
busy leading our lives you know so we
tend to accept those terms of service
and also in our mind is well if I don't
like apples Terms of Service I could go
over to an Android phone but the time it
takes to move all of your data and all
of your apps and all of your photos in
some apps you can have to buy again
these things create conditions and
environments where firms have real power
over up at firms so Apple uses its
control over its App Store that lets you
choose the apps that your phone has on
it and they're very I mean up to a point
they're very open about the fact that
they do curate it and they have a
variety of criteria that decide whether
you may present your app on that phone
to these several tens of millions of
users of that phone platform or not and
some of those criteria are secrets and
so Kumar openly stated these are
positions of real power or you know take
google again since we mentioned Android
right Google it's search function is a
classic Network effect you know Google
has individualized searches everyone
knows my search for a term well my
search results on Google won't be the
same as yours
well Google now I think it's hard to
disagree that Google is arguably the
most important company but you could
argue that it governs the Internet today
and when people are worried about a
virus or interested in a political
candidate or anything else everyone
turns to Google they couldn't me by the
way it's such a useful service because
so many of us use it it has extremely
refined search algorithms because of all
the data but our billions of searches
have put into it over time so there's
that market aspect where I believe you
can show that capitalism allows for real
power in the marketplace and just to say
I think the supplies on a more
individual level to if your figure like
just to take a clear case like Mike
Bloomberg is worth 60 odd billion
dollars through his semi monopolistic
Bloomberg terminal business with that he
can peel off 1/64 of his work
it's about a billion bucks and run for
president and yeah that went down in
flames fine but he was on every screen
in America and every YouTube video I
think the manifestation of power in the
marketplace is very clear looking at
these facts and that would I think
represent real issues as far as our
negative freedom and our ability to be
free from external power in the
marketplace we agree the state is
powerful that's open shop so your honor
I'd love to hear you respond to that I
mean that the ways that Rob is
describing corporations being able to
acquire power doesn't that in some sense
restrict the power of those not in those
privileged positions that Rob has
described well I don't think freedom has
to do with power the you know power
isn't wood has negative connotations and
it's not clear exactly what it means for
example I think it's really really
important to separate two forms of power
I think it's important to separate
economic power from political power I
think they're very different and one is
clearly coercive and the other is not
economic power is fundamentally
voluntary it's fundamentally an issue of
choice now it is true your choices might
be limited to having no phone having an
Apple phone or having an Android phone
or maybe you could go to one of those
old flip flow flip phones they still
exists and by the way I remember I'm old
enough you guys might not be to remember
that somehow we survived in the world
with flip phones without smartphones so
that's not an option that means death
and destruction it's actually an option
that's available out there so my
interaction with any one of these firms
that Robb's mentioned is a volunteer
interaction I can interact or not
interact indeed I sometimes use Bing for
a search when I don't want necessarily
Google and they're actually encrypted
searches now there's search engines that
have encryption where you can really
feel secure and private and the beauty
of the market is it's produced that it's
produced options it's just most of us
don't care that Google has that
information and are willing to give it
to them so this issue of voluntary is
really really important when somebody
has large market power but that power is
economic power therefore voluntary power
that's great
I have no
and I don't think anybody should the
power that scares me is the power of the
gun the power that says you don't behave
the way we want you to behave you go to
jail or we take some of your money or we
penalize you physically literally
physically that to me is coercion that
is authoritarianism that is violence
that is what I want to extract from
human society if we want to have
civilization civilization to me is when
we don't deal in violence civilization
to me is the now interactions of
voluntary interactions where we choose
to interact or not and look I could
complete with Rob with regard to the
network effects I think it's actually
quite beautiful that that we we have a
we have a world in which these network
effects have manifested the first
company where we really realized network
effects was a Microsoft and of course
you know their government tried to break
them up try to use that political force
the violence the coercion of throat
Arianism why by the way because they
were offering a product for free it was
it was an internet browser and indeed
all the examples that Rob gave not all
of them but many of them a stunning in
that Facebook is free Google is free and
if you want to restrict your your the
ability to use the information you know
putting a site when they cheat on that
but when you want to restrict the
information you can set the settings to
strict what kind of your privacy
settings or what cut what they get we
all can make those kind of choices so
what the system is created this system
of big tech is this amazing world where
we got a lot of stuff for free where we
actually have unbelievable choices and
when we have something like Facebook
when before Facebook there was nothing
like Facebook and because Rob is right
that you need the networking effect yeah
some companies are gonna dominate those
spaces but that's just the reality of it
I want to I want to say one other thing
as we get into concrete examples as a
general point we don't live in my view I
think objectively in a cow
we don't live in a socialist world
either the world in which we live is a
mixed economy we have elements of
capitalism in it we have some private
property we have some freedom as as
consumers as workers as producers but we
also are constrained we have lots of
regulations we have lots of taxes
different types of taxes that it advise
us to do all kinds of things we have
cronyism with some big companies use the
government in order to control a
particular space so I you know I fear
that I don't want this conversation to
go look the world as today isn't working
and that's this is an example of
capitalism when you know let's be honest
it's not it's I can argue that every
problem that we have today is caused by
regulations and gum and control and
cronyism and all of that you know
and of course it's I wouldn't argue that
all the things that are going on today
is socialism I think it's government
control but not in the form of
necessarily of socialism so when I when
we talk about tech tech has evolved in a
relatively free environment relatively
free of regulation but not completely
free relatively free of cronyism but not
not any more as we know these companies
now are pretty crony and a pretty
protective and this is not an example of
what happens when you have complete free
markets but to the extent that they've
been free Wow
I mean anybody who's lived through the
last 40 50 years should be inspired by
how wonderful the tech industry you know
the wool the wonderful world the tech
industry has created for us relative to
what it was like before we had it
eventually I want to get broach
specifically the topic of health care a
little bit but I'm curious Rob as you
listen to your on say that the economic
is not coercive but the political power
is do you do you even accept that notion
or would you challenge that notion as a
fundamental principle yeah that's
exactly I think we the core of the issue
is yes I think it's great to address
that right on so earlier on said that
freedom and power aren't necessarily
related I just want to clarify that in
the
and that thinking dealt productively to
the rest of this um as far as this
relationship I tend to favor the
conservative writings you know in my
book on capitalism and freedom I take a
look at the most prominent right-wing
conservative or libertarian writers you
know starting with the more popular ones
like no free man and Hayek and then
getting into the more somewhat obscure
theoretical ones like Murray Rothbard
and someone and they're getting very
broad just kind of public messages more
power for the government imposes on your
negative freedom if the government gains
some new way to control you that imposes
on your negative freedom so to me just
again another a broad level of course
the connection between them is more
power exercised on you means less
freedom for you in that simple negative
freedom way so that's sort of the basic
framework there now he wants main point
was the economic power unlike state
power is voluntary okay well again
there's a lot of variety in markets and
you can find a particular market that
meets any kind of pattern but I think
broadly it's sort of difficult to draw
that distinction so one example I like
just to kind of get us going and this
connects to healthcare I suppose as well
it would be the EpiPen
which some folks would be familiar with
if you have someone in your family with
a major allergy to bee stings or peanuts
and so on the EpiPen is this little
plastic pen you can buy and it contains
an epinephrine shot you know an
adrenaline shot so that you don't have
to break out an actual hospital needle
when your little brother gets stung by a
bee at recess you don't have to stab
them in the heart with an adrenalin
needle like in Pulp Fiction you can use
this nice little plastic thing that's
kid-friendly and delivers a specific
dose well the front my lawn has had a
monopoly on those consumer ready one
dose adrenaline injectables for some
time and one thing I got to point out
here because this is you know healthcare
and drug related you kind of think of
patent rights in this case which of
course are a major state policy that has
lots of do with the pharmaceutical
industry and others but the EpiPen has
been out of patents for years it's just
extremely difficult to produce for a
time there are only two firms making it
eight oligopoly as we say and one of
them was having difficulties controlling
the dosage and the Sanitation which you
have to have of course with an
injectable product like that and so
they're off the market from the time we
retool I mean over this period my loss
raise the price of a two pack of these
things to 600 bucks now
I mean we can't control what things we
have allergies and the you know which
were born with which we experience so if
I'm a working mom who's struggling to
pay the bills I have to come up with 600
bucks every six months or so because
these things have a limited shelf life
right would argue like that would be an
example of a clear imposition of using
economic power to limit the Liberty in
the sense that we're taking assets from
people who are on the demand side of
that I think there are a lot of examples
that are so similar to that if less
immediately extreme so you're on
mentioned Microsoft again which i think
is a great case it's very true
the state government the US feds I
didn't attempt to break up Microsoft and
actually secured a ruling to that effect
but then the Bush administration came in
and they ended the Justice Department's
pursuit of a divestiture you know
breaking up Microsoft and so chilliad
other company to this day you know well
it wasn't just because they're offering
a free product right Microsoft has a
fairly long and lurid record of crushing
competitors and I mean actually I will
say this you take a look at the book
mostly my sources on this are business
journalists who are broadly speaking
sympathetic with the value that
Microsoft's created with its operating
system and again the clear value these
networks that we're talking about so
Microsoft has a history where they'd see
some new competitor that might threaten
their Windows operating system software
for example and they say we're
interested in maybe a partnership with
you firm let's share code and as soon as
Microsoft sees the code they then say
actually we're planning on our own very
similar software product so we're not
gonna work with you and able to sort of
crush firms in that way another example
since we met you Facebook Facebook the
Wall Street Journal has covered this a
couple of times very thoughtful business
journalism for investors and executives
who need good information to run their
business empires they make sure Facebook
has a whole department within the firm
with a number of people working on it
whose whole job is to watch for emerging
threats to Facebook and Instagram and
its other social networking platforms
and Wall Street Journal actually I just
have to refer to this because it makes
me laugh they said that they're on the
lookout for any firm that could disrupt
facebook and they say without irony so
I'm not sure if they knew that that was
kind of funny or not I think these are
real examples of firms using their
market
to take over another sector and again
Microsoft was specifically in trouble
for using its operating system
monopolies to crush Netscape Navigator
and promote its yes totally free to the
consumer point of purchase its Internet
Explorer browser you know but after it
used its market power to crush another
industry that ran into foul of the
Antitrust Act one other thing I'll just
say quickly where I think we can see the
tech firms revealing sort of the issues
of power that we see in the marketplace
is power internal to the firm you know
because when you're in a job you
typically don't have the power to tell
your boss where to stick it even when he
might need to hear that and that's an
issue you know the me2 movement I think
is really shown how much power a lot of
executives are able to wield over
individual members of their staff and to
the extent that workers don't feel they
can just pack up and move to another
town and start a new job speaks to the
fact that there's so many elasticity in
that market people don't want to
immediately upend their whole lives
because of a scumbag boss who bullies
them and I mention this because Tech
which I didn't expect but just to said
read through the record what you find is
that these tech CEOs have pretty
impressive records of being bullying
scumbags from the clock Jeff Bezos who's
kind of famous for her Steve Jobs of
course everyone knows he was a jerk you
know well people don't just quit their
jobs and move on to a similar firm that
doesn't have bullying there's a small
number of firms in these markets and
they have a lot of pull and you know
just want to piss off your big-time
famous celebrity CEO for bullying you in
the workplace or screaming at you and do
it what these guys do which is mostly
yelling in front of other people
at their subordinates we don't get an
argument sometimes but fighting and
yelling at someone whom I can fire power
issues I think arise and you can see the
implications for freedom there so you're
on feel free to take any element of that
that you want I think it would be
interesting the EpiPen thing that seems
like a status quo that limits the
freedom of someone who is potentially
depending on that EpiPen to keep keep
themselves or a loved one alive how does
how is capitalism consistent with
freedom in the EpiPen example
well first capitalism created the EpiPen
it would be no it depend if not for
capitalism and indeed all these things
were complaining about a products of
capitalism they don't even come around
they don't become
options for consumers and the whole idea
of consumers and producers and having a
job and having a boss these are all
conceptions of capitalism so you don't
get a epipen without capitalism to begin
with now let's be let's be real about
this again right medical there's the
health care industry and we can talk
more about healthcare happy to it's not
exactly a free market this is a market
dominated by government dominated by the
FDA and indeed at least one competitor
the EpiPen was was was kicked out of the
US I think it was a French company by
the FDA and not a-- by consumers not by
marcus not by a private organization
that said but by the fda and i don't
know if there was justified in terms of
the quality or not you know I'm
skeptical whenever the FDA says maybe
somebody maybe somebody with some
cronyism influenced them to do something
that they you know who knows the FDA is
not exactly one of my most trusted
organizations and I think the corona a
problem we have right now is is a good
illustration of how awful the FDA is and
I think the logic that always has been
um three competitors a coming to the
forefront right now with regard to
EpiPen you've got stories in 2018 that
three different companies have applied
to the FDA to try to get to try to
compete with EpiPen because you're right
it's out a patent so these are generics
the problem of course is that it's very
expensive to get approval from the FDA
and to go through the whole process and
to get everything done also nobody
actually pays and we all know this $600
for an EpiPen though that mother who is
you know single mothers trying to make a
living does not pay $600 for an EpiPen
all these things at discounted you can
go to the pharmacy today and the
pharmacist will tell you hey look up
this website you can find a coupon for
the drug and it'll knock ninety percent
off the price and you can show them to
their hope drug pricing medical placing
is such a disaster and a mess has
nothing zero to do with capitalism
capitalism encourages price disclosure
encourages encourages consumers to get
involved and encourages competition
between hospitals between manufacturers
between drug companies none of that
exists because of the way government is
regulated I mean to go into drug pricing
right now with all the different
elements it is so convoluted and complex
no market economy would ever ever
produce what we have today what we have
today is this combination of you know a
little bit of private and all this
government intervention including the
fact that government is the largest
payer for health care you know over 60%
of all dollars spent on health care in
the United States are spent by the
government primarily Medicare Medicaid
which I think you know I'm a capitalist
I don't think should exist um let me
address this crushing competition um
surely you know I want to crush my
competition all right you know I want
everybody I'm a bunny hedge fund I want
everybody give me money not my
competitors the question is how do you
do it now if Microsoft crushed its
competition through fraud which is one
of the examples you gave then we have
well-established mechanisms to deal with
that and this should be dealt with and
that's what capitalism should that's
what the government should focus on is
is is stopping fraud because faut is
clearly a violation of rights clearly
coercive but if crushing competition
means either buying your competitor poor
competitors they got bought out and they
all became billion millionaires I mean I
really feel sorry for the Instagram or
the whatsup founders I mean really
miserable or it means that they offer a
product in competition remember Netscape
I mean I remember Netscape because I
used I downloaded Netscape it had pay
$70 and 70 bucks for browser we all
today take browsers for granted we don't
pay for them it was a Microsoft
innovation to offered free notice that
today I don't use Internet Explorer I
doubt either of you use Internet
Explorer I don't even use Safari that
comes with my Mac I use Chrome or I
could use Firefox there at least for
good browsers out there all free and in
all competing markets so what what
exactly did Microsoft do badly it it
succeeded success means you defeated
your competition success means you were
better than competition
some dimension good for them I'm a huge
fan of people who succeed and I find it
hilarious that we penalize success I
actually consider in this context
against it an antitrust kind of the
first the first blow against capitalism
in the u.s. now us wasn't that
capitalist given that it had slavery but
post slavery the first real blow against
capitalism is is antitrust laws I think
antitrust laws a horrific violation
again coercive actions again individuals
and look this idea that bosses yell at
subordinates sure bosses yelled
subordinate husbands yells at wives
wives yell at husbands and and people
can walk away and people do the tech
industry is great example for this I
know a lot of my friends work in Silicon
Valley a lot of them I know very few of
them who've kept a job out of their own
choice for more than a couple of years
they flip jobs all the time and now I
hired I'm running a startup and I hire
you and I'm investing a lot of energy
and training you and getting you up to
speed on this product and six months
later you leave because somebody else
offers you a better price great good for
you is my attitude but let's not make
this as if it's at your can I can
understand in in some relationships as
clearly a disadvantage certainly some
blue collar jobs and everything pretty
high-tech workers have a huge
negotiating power they easily moved away
and look I'm never I'm not gonna excuse
anybody who abuses their position for
sexual favors or anything like that I
think it's horrific I think it's it
should be denounced and when it spills
into things like rape they should go to
jail and we should throw away the keys
right so I'm a huge supportive of me too
in that sense but you can leave and it
it's it's again and you can you can let
the world know that this guy's a creep
and a bad guy and you know what would I
would I want to work for Steve Jobs and
be yelled at once a day absolutely I
would pay I would literally pay to be
able to go back in time and work for
Steve Jobs and having yelled at me once
in a while you know what and
not sexually abused me granted but yell
at me wait say work for genius like that
who you know we should be so thankful
that the Jeff bees us and the Steve
Jobs's of the world exist because every
single day and particularly now under
you know under house arrest basically
you know how could I exist without Jeff
Bezos without Amazon without without the
efficiency the productivity the price
points that they provide hey you know
how would I exist without all this
wonderful tech that we have we take for
granted the Skype that microsoft owns
yes they bought it from a start-up all
of this amazing stuff that I'm not gonna
argue you know 100 percent capitalist
but the tech industry's closest to
capitalist of any other industry
it's the freest of any under the sea and
look at the amazing world in which we
live in the 21st century and to use this
technology to denounce what made it
possible to me is is is a little
ridiculous these giants made it it
doesn't excuse horrible behavior but you
know I don't know that yelling if
somebody wants in a wall and really
being principled and think about
beautiful the iPhone is would that have
been created if the boss had been well
we can compromise and maybe settle and
maybe do this I mean no Steve Jobs had
won a vision and he you know made that
vision real in the world and thank you
Steve Jobs to sticking your principles
not compromising and making all of our
lives and I here I thank you for all of
us maybe not you and everybody else for
making Oliver lies so much better our
lives are dramatically improved because
of these great geniuses and I think and
let me end on this I mean this is what
has happened in the tech world which is
not being regulated if we had taken that
model the model by the way that existed
at the turn of the century in America
and applied it to automobiles and
applied it to energy and applied it's a
health care and maybe even say education
Wow imagine the progress the innovation
the success the economic growth wage the
prosperity that we would be living under
today I think I think our health care
system is is her
the only health care systems worse than
it ones that are socialized like in
Israel where my father is a physician in
socialized healthcare and I would take
American healthcare system any day over
that but what it could be if it was free
what our educational system could be if
it was not monopolized real monopolies
because it's by a gun by the state
imagine what all these industries I mean
we would have the flying cars that we
all imagined when we were young if only
we got the curse of power of governments
out of the way and letting you know let
entrepreneurs create and produce and
make and innovate so Rob I'm glad for
you to respond to that but I also think
it would be useful now that we've you've
issued some critiques of capitalism and
Iran has provided some defenses it would
be interesting to hear from you how
socialism would deal with these problems
to really ascertain whether these are
maybe issued so for example antitrust
you could have a company that is
organized in a socialist manner that is
or is not prevented from monopolistic
behavior based on government regulations
so I think it would be interesting to
hear you address a little bit about how
the system you favor would deal with
some of the issues you've pointed out or
whether they are more issues of
government regulation or something else
right on yeah
well yes so first to look at the
innovation issue is she wrong rightfully
brings up which i think is great clearly
completely right you know the tech
industry has utterly transformed our
social landscape in many ways for the
better but we all like recognize that
you know we give those famous photos of
you know Pope Ratzinger Colonel
Ratzinger visiting the United States and
a few years later visiting again and the
first picture it's everyone's cheering
and the second picture it's everyone
holding up a phone for a picture so
transforming the society with these
amazingly useful new technologies is an
open-and-shut case
and the first page of my book I
specifically say let me say I use these
companies products all the time as Iran
was saying you know I'm who would deny
that they rely on these products
constantly especially as he said under
quarantine we rely on them north now
that
I would actually argue so I think that's
all very true but to argue that this
will that the innovation that the
technology itself comes from the
industry is a matter of the factual
record and the record is the opposite of
what is usually stated here so we can
look at this from the most foundational
level I think most folks are aware that
the early days of the fundamental
research into what became the Internet
were managed through various parts of
the state sector you know so the
original name for what became the
internet was DARPA net because it was
the first instance developed by the
Defense Advanced Research Projects
administration which is the Pentagon's
research on along with the big tech
relevant universities gradually
developing this internet work technology
but also the technology and the
smartphone's themselves from the GPS
which is largely a military innovation
to the smartphone display itself which
amazingly was actually originally
developed at that certain particle lab
in Europe if you're looking to be like a
relatively well-established history of
you know the record of these innovations
and how they happen and even the tech
platforms themselves I mean remember
Google's original web address who's not
google.com it was Google dot
stanford.edu because you developing a
new technology and you know anyone who
is a science background we familiar with
this when you're doing scientific or
technological research there's no
guarantee you're gonna get anywhere with
your particular line of research and
certainly no guarantee that it's gonna
make your firm or you money anytime soon
so historically if we look at a lot of
the history of innovation it's certainly
intact which is the case I know about
the best what you see is largely public
sector research I think just reflecting
the nature of the fact the science it's
uncertain whether you will ever make any
money so if we look at figures like
Bezos or Steve Jobs we mentioned earlier
and we refer to these figures as
geniuses I really think it's difficult
to substantiate that on the record
I mean Steve Jobs in particular is
famous for the terrible design decisions
that he made while working at Apple from
the Lisa computer all the way to later
max it was he who wanted to close the
system off so that third-party app
developers could make their own apps
which is every industry history that
I've seen says that's why Windows is so
dominant it's not because people love
winter so much clearly it's me
Mack was a closed platform and you see
because he made the same mistake again
in the mobile era when for very long
time he refused to allow any new apps
being developed by third-party firms
other than specific ones like alphabet
for its google apps and so on
eventually lessening bad with the Apple
Store which they still control so I
think a history of innovation there it's
difficult to support the claim that that
comes primarily from the private sector
and it could be argued that that's
because of the current rate should we
have in the economy today which as no
one said is a mixed economy I think
that's fine but to say that Microsoft's
you know succeeded and we're punishing
it for its success it has Network
effects in that market network effects
like economies of scale and others these
things give firms strong reasons to get
big and to absorb competitors and
takeover markets and get big and then
you have the market wait to crush your
competitors which i think is something
that does raise freedom consent so
getting to your other question know how
in socialist economies management manage
these kinds of issues well to me the
idea of socialism like we said is worker
control of production
very few socialist today you want hyper
authoritarian government control where
state approval is required for every
decision but it's when we're looking at
big capital no one's saying that the
state or the local community or workers
should be able to tell you what clothes
to wear and what smartphone you can have
but if you own an oil refinery or a you
know a soybean plantation or the telecom
wires that bring the internet to big
regions of the country that's not just
your personal stuff anymore I think you
can argue strongly that you do cross a
line with nature property to where you
have power you have power over the
society power over specific parts of the
economy the goal as I've seen with
socialism would be to have a real free
socialist society where were spared the
power plays of powerful corporations as
we would want to be from authoritarian
state influence to and this would mean
work of control it might mean lowered
productivity because now the workforce
is involved in these decision-making
processes that normally management
reserves to itself but I think that's a
price that would be reasonable if we
consider the fact that it would again
preserve our negative freedom by no
longer making us the playthings at the
corporate world but also we would have
some of that positive freedom I think it
can be argued that once
society reaches a stage where it could
provide health care to all of its
citizens where it's materially capable
of providing housing twelve of its
citizens but we don't because they're
poor or for maybe their own or maybe
because daddy was poor or their mom was
a meth addict so the kids born addicted
to meth like which is a thing sadly
which of course occurs I think there's a
strong argument to be made then a free
socialism could improve that negative
freedom and give us some of that
positive freedom to benefit from the
many many important goods and services
that were producing today I think
there's an argument there so what do you
think you're on I mean it sounds it
sounds like that's an opportunity as Rob
lays it out to increase the amount of
freedom if we were to reorganize Society
in the direction that he's suggesting
well if I can can i address the the
innovation [ __ ] shoulder let me quickly
do that I won't spend a lot of time on
it but yes there's no question all the
examples that Rob gave us through the
government did develop these things as a
basic science and indeed any time a
government enters any space it crowds
out private capital it's a well-known
phenomena the crowding out phenomena and
it does that in in in basic science but
the fact is that for 150 years
government did almost really zero
investment in basic science during the
19th century government invested zero in
any scientific endeavor engineering
endeavor really until the the the the
New Deal
and and really until really after World
War two when they really started
investing science fallish during that
period innovation arguably was even
higher significantly higher than it is
today
automobiles trains electricity all these
things happened on a Plains on a scale
that today regulators wouldn't allow any
of those to happen because you know one
of the reasons we have innovation a tech
and not in the physical spaces Tech's
at a you know electrons and we haven't
yet figured out how to regulate
electrons but we can figure out how to
regulate the physical world pretty well
and and we've stopped all innovation in
the physical world it's it's a really
one of the tragic occurrences of the
20th and 21st century is that there's
almost no affair
in the physical world so yes I all of
those you know Stanford is a private
university but all the university system
in a capitalist society would be private
it's not like anti capitalism there no
universities and researchers wouldn't be
doing science and and all this thing
wouldn't be happening that that is
absurd it would happen it would happen
in my view more efficiently and of
course there's the issue of usefulness
government produces in these labs in
these laboratories produce all kinds of
stuff and but to turn it into something
that's actually useful it's actually
something that we all use and consume
and could you you need you need the
people you need the Steve Jobs's of the
world you need the Jesus of the world
I'll put that aside the lots of say just
on that topic there's a huge amount but
but you know let's remember doll you
know these guys in the 19th century that
really major steps forward we're not all
government-funded
socialism so the only way you can you
are claiming to be able to help bring
some choices to people who maybe have
fewer choices or some opportunities to
people is by using coercion on other
people so there's no way you know
socialism is a zero-sum game it is
whatever you are providing to son you
are taking from others whether you're
taking through Coase of taxation all
taxation is coercive you're using a gun
whether you're taking by breaking up
companies literally physically going in
and saying which you created is not
yours and if you don't want to use
Microsoft's example because yes some of
the technology will light on something
government did we can use a big company
in the 19th century or 20th century that
had no cronyism no government funding
and you're breaking them up right by
what right do you have to come into my
house and say your house is too big we
want to break it up into two houses no
it's my house I built it I made it I
paid for it I paid my employees for it
I have not free ridden on anybody in
order to get this and who are you to
decide what's too big how do we decide
what this government entity is going to
be the decides to be so what you get is
some kind of authoritarianism in
disguised in democratic terms where the
majority oppresses them I know
which is exactly our form of government
in the United States and it's in its
origins were supposed to protect the
minority from exactly that with all its
flaws that was at least its goal you
create a system in which if I want to
compete with your socialist enterprise
as a capitalist enterprise you you you
abandoned you cannot allow it and if I
get too successful you will break me up
your world and the socialist world and
again I've lived in it I know what it
looks like I've experienced that I've
been in socialized healthcare it's a
world of violence it's a world of force
it's a world of authoritarianism it's a
world of no innovation I take Israel
Israel as a great example of this
because it was a socialist country the
founders of former communists who became
who rejected communism was socialist and
it's in its founding and then in the
late 70s and early 80s it shifted
direction and it's nowhere near
capitalist it's it's much more of a
mixed economy now from socialism
it wasn't socialist in in the Communist
sense but it was social social democracy
was a social democracy and it was poor
and as soon as I left and it shifted to
become more free its boomed it's boom
everybody in as well as better off today
the innovation the the progress the
prosperity the the building the growth
is just stunning and the same arguably a
you know we don't have time to get into
this example the same by the way
happened in Sweden swings a great
example of this Sweden which was one of
the freest countries in the world one of
those capitalist countries in the world
then became socialist which made it poor
then as abandoned socialism in the last
20 since 1994 and is now doing well
again
I you know I wish that America embraced
many of the policies that Sweden has
because the formal capitalist and what
the United States has socialism crushes
the human spirit because it does not
allow for individuals to be free to
pursue their values their chosen values
to produce to innovate to dream to
create you don't get that in any
socialist country even in health care in
spite of all the problems we have in the
United States 70 plus percent of all
medical innovations happen here because
we still have a little bit of freedom
not much a little bit in Europe there's
very little innovation because there's
no freedom there all government
employees Rob feel free to go directly
back with the you know your your
response to that critique of the system
that you're proposing yeah I think
that's these get these questions get
right to the heart of the issue so yeah
you're on mentioned like by what right
do you break up someone's firm that they
have built up yeah just an authoritarian
aspect there and so on this very
reasonable question here but to me the
line like what's too successful what's
too
you know why should someone get their
friend broken up it's I think reasonable
to talk about drawing a line where it
gets to where you're an extremely
powerful entity to me again the
relationship between power and freedom
is really relevant here once a firm
reaches a certain level of concentration
where it has 80% market share 90% market
share we can debate exactly where the
line is like we do on any other legal
subject we end up settling on some sort
of threshold that we designate so to me
that sort of technical aspect can be
argued about but to me the real line is
at what point does some firm end up
having so much control over a market
segment or its employees over some
important technology that's the issue
that brings up the question of why
should they you know at some point be
imposed upon by their workers who go on
a sit-down strike and socialize the firm
or something like that so I think that's
at least something to consider there I
mean to me the closest metaphor for this
would be when you think about something
like a warlord you know so in Libya
right now is since the US intervention
under great secretary Clinton's
leadership completely collapsed in a
heinous civil anarchy and there's
outright slavery there again which about
as bad as it gets for the record of
intermission it goes back to slavery
well that's a do-over I guess we take a
look there one of the things that people
want the most in societies like Libya or
others that are just torn by fundamental
civil strife you know as bad as we have
it a quarantine now it does get much
worse in the world of course well there
when societies try to move out of that
kind of thing like say Somalia at 20
years ago trying to get past a period a
civil war and warlord action one of the
basic goals is to disarm warlords we're
taking away property from you then you
have illegitimately
something that lets you control other
people maybe you pay for those nice
automatic firearms I'm very sorry but
this gives you too much power over
people you know and I think this is a
scenario that we see very frequently in
the marketplace you know and just
generally it's not about considering
people's stuff sacrosanct it's once you
have the ability to control the
livelihoods of millions of people that
we couldn't legitimately consider some
kind of actually yes perhaps its
antitrust which Iran is right that
really was the first step we took away
from pure or the pure and they say fair
capitalism of the Gilded Age which
slavery I agree that's sort of the ear
of fully free markets that we want today
but severe of huge fortunes of large
monopolies in many industries extreme
chronic economic instability I mean only
what we're going through right now can
match what they saw in the 1890s history
if you want but I think those are some
of the issues that come up and it's very
reasonable to explore these subjects but
again to me I like to just take the
conservative writers like Friedman and
Hayek at their word
we don't want power in our society
deciding what happens and once you reach
a point where a market has a tiny
handful of firms with very limited
competition amongst them and you have
internally very strict hierarchies in
the workplace where your boss can scream
at you know anyone if they're a genius I
still think you shouldn't abuse your
workforce we could debate that right now
that might be a personal preference
issue but I think that sort of speaks to
these fundamental issues so we're we're
gonna go back to you in a second your
honor we're starting to get to the end
of our time and I want to bring up
something that is it's really not
trivial and you know living in a mixed
economy it's very easy to say okay Iran
wants to tell us more in this direction
whereas Rob wants to pull us more in
this other direction but consider the
incompatibility of on the take the word
violence that you guys have applied to
these terms
Iran has asserted if I understand him
correctly that the violence is the
government coming in and doing the
regulating whereas Rob has asserted if I
understand him correctly that the
violence is done by those that go
unregulated when they accumulate too
much power this is this is not a trivial
distinction and I wonder how I mean the
once you understand that we're very far
apart here you're on our aren't we I
think we are but I think I think the
viewers should really think about where
Rob went with his last comments because
I think it's very revealing we all know
what violence is give me a break the war
loads in Libya that kind of violence is
not the same as a boss firing his
employee there is a real real difference
a category difference these are two
different categories me pointing an m16
at you with I mean reasonable belief
that I would pull the trigger and me
saying get out of my office
you're fired I'm not the same category
we can maybe say that firing somebody is
not good it's not nice it's not pleasant
it's not a lot of things it's not
violence guys so I agree completely
regarding Libya example the one thing we
should do is eliminate violence for
society and I am a believer Minh has a
huge role in regulating firearms because
firearms are things of violence and the
one thing government must do is regulate
violence in other words eliminate
violence from society it's only job in
my view is to do that in arbitrary
disputes so that they don't get violent
so my view is sever the thing that is
the real danger for civilization a thing
that threatens freedom the things that
threaten my ability to pursue my life in
pursuit of my values is violence in all
its forms but violence right where I get
something from you not by negotiating
with you not through some kind of mutual
agreement a contract something like that
but by pulling out a gun or by lying to
you by committing fraud fraud is a form
of violence firing somebody is not there
is a clear distinction so I you know
breaking up a company that's violence
and and we could argue about where the
line is worth or Tyrion starts but
authoritarianism starts once you cross
that line I don't want to
authoritarianism I don't want to cross
that line I don't believe
anybody should be broken up ever I don't
have any problem with market derived
economic power I think indeed because of
the network effect exactly for the
reason you started out with it is
essential to have big companies because
the only way we assume is can benefit
from network effect is if we allow them
to get to size I think economies of
scale are often not always often
beautiful things because they allow
producers to make products cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper so that we can
benefit more and it raises our standard
of living
you know waka Fela is a very good
example of that um so you know violence
absolutely we need to negate that from
society but it's let's be honest about
what violence actually means finding
somebody finding somebody is no worse in
my view then somebody leaving a job so
if I'm gonna restrict it in being able
to fire an employee is he gonna be
restricted in leaving no because those
restrictions are violations of my
freedom they are the violence the
restriction is the violence not me
saying some to somebody you can't be on
my property or somebody saying I don't
want to work for you anymore I'm leaving
I'm going away and in the tech industry
we know that happens all the time so I'm
for freedom freedom to voluntary
associate and the freedom to voluntarily
unassociated and under conditions that
are determined as as well as possible in
advance that's the beauty of contracts
contracts of beautiful things and yes
they've been distorted we don't read
those disclosures because you know let's
again a legal system is nuts you know
we've gone away away from respecting
private property and and all the laws
and the dictates that require
disclosures I mean I like to have
contracts with people I do business with
that our onepages
and they're writing in English and if
the lawyers touch them then they're
gonna be so you know all I want is true
freedom which means true voluntary
Association volunteer relationship and
again if you want to start just you're
so shows company over here run by the
Union runs whether I have no objection
to that I love
Aesop's wish we're you know employees
get shares or let employees vote the
managers let that company compete
with the company that doesn't have that
that's the beauty of capitalism we can
try different models and see what works
go ahead Rob yeah I mean so so feel free
to take on directly whether this issue
of what constitutes violence is really
the intractable disagreement or any
other element there right on yes there's
a lot of meaty stuff in here and of
course yeah we have limited time folks
watching this [ __ ] dig into our books
we've learned a little bit about this so
the printed word is how you get really
into the meat of it I'm sure everyone
here so getting back to what you're not
said though about the mixed economy I
think something he said there is
extremely accurate which is once you
have like partially regulated markets
and very large powerful firms it just
becomes like the outcome of that is a
system that's just the outcome of a
tug-of-war between in my view opposing
powerful centers of authority and the
outcome is completely right it's a God
forsaken mess that's impossible to argue
I so I think that's very reasonable
as you said the real issue here is you
know what is violence what is coercion
at the stake case again I think everyone
agrees on that if you don't pay your
taxes you go to jail the state can't
rafter you like these are clear
manifestations of state authority no one
I know of would disagree with that but I
think it can be argued also that in a
scenario where I control the arable land
of elation or all of the freshwater and
I say I'm not gonna give you any I let
you starve I think it can be argued that
that's an instance and things like that
are instances of economic coercion I
remember John Stuart Mill in his book on
Liberty which is a great tiny enormous
you take a look at it it's mostly about
negative freedom and how all the limited
circumstances where the state can coerce
you like your own said it's mostly to
prevent violence against other people
that's fine but a careful reading I
think show is that positive freedom
appears in his conception of it remember
on when the you could see the page
number in my book but he says a man
might as well be killed as excluded from
the means of earning his bread it
perhaps I would suggest lending some
support to the idea of positive freedom
there if you monopolized an economic
resource whether it's oil like
Rockefeller or food and some other
example there is a way you can exclude
people from that and create a real
coercive relationship absent pulling out
a gun or an
and then again this is a thing we can
dig into a little bit when I look at
today's modern gigantic corporate
empires the huge amount of market share
they have the way they're able to
dominate industries the fascinating
story time for where Google and Apple
conspired illegally as it came out in
court to fix the wages of many of their
technology or their software code
writers and so on with a number of other
firms and eventually they did get caught
but they succeeded for a number of years
with that I think this is going to show
that economic power is a real thing that
coercion is very very conceivable within
the marketplace I think that there's
some relevance there and finally I think
the last point is really important that
you're on made which is like economies
of scale Network effects and so on they
show something that we would agree on
which is there's compelling economic
reasons for big production for big
economic institutions people I would
totally agreed fail to recognize the
value of things like economies of scale
you produce it a huge volume of goods
you can push the cost down and that
tends to mean you know at times lower
prices for consumers more revenue and
profitability for the firm it depends on
the broader market conditions there
those things are extremely important in
to me big economic institutions are the
reason for this whole debate if we were
still in the sixteen hundreds and most
of the economy is small-scale feudal
farming or a local home handicraft
industry no there's not much economic
power there apart from the Lord and the
king themselves you know the state power
that we all recognize once you're
looking at a world of gigantic data
centers that hold all of our information
on them or a modern smartphone ship
manufacturing plants those things cost a
billion bucks to put up now we're
talking about a real economic
installation if I decide to close it
down tomorrow there go a huge amount of
jobs and access to data to me that's
where there is a line and you can see
the realities of economic coercion at
least being a concern at that point and
that might help people think about this
so you're on now we started with Rob so
I want to end with you and I would love
for you to the example that Rob gives is
an interesting one and I'd be curious
whether you would concede that it is a
form of violence if through the
accumulation of economic power which
you've said you do not feel is coerced
I obtained control of all of the water
resources in a given area and I restrict
the the access to the surrounding
population to water would that not be an
economic form of power and economic
instance of power that that is violent
in a literal way we need water to
survive right so we need a science
fiction example in order to get a
capitalism we finally have to I mean no
no capitalist economy has ever produced
that let's say you had you know all the
water supply you can't stop me from
building a desalination plant on the
coast and to annex old water into
regular water you can't stop me from
building a tank that collects rainwater
and supplies my own supply of water if
it's on my land you can't stop me for
building a well into the ground I mean
no you know what restricts is when you
restrict my action what restricts now
yes you can cook you can you know you
buy the land surround me and don't give
me access through that land I mean I've
heard them all right sure in any
common-law way back in England under
private property it's understood that
access is something that is allowed
under private property you can't
surround somebody and not allow them
access you could argue that if you did
somehow monopolize all the water in the
world in my examples didn't count you
know you'd have to give some access but
I doubt that because a the example is I
think sci-fi and ridiculous and be I
think that as long as people have a mind
as long as people are free to act on
that mind they will find ways to find
water and to get around your
monopolistic so-called monopolistic
behavior as they always do there's a
little mean kind of thing going on on
Facebook or whatever showing the changes
in tech company dominance over the last
twenty thirty years and the shifts I
mean do you remember when oh now the
name slips my mind you know anyway a you
you Yahoo gerini you know there was a
company before yo-yo dominated it
dominated everything nobody who googles
gogo is this
a couple of kids at Stanford doing
something I you know how to change very
quickly and I wouldn't be surprised if
we did this ten years for now Google
wasn't a small company but there was
somebody already challenging them and
maybe taking over and the same with
bamas on minoo it's it's it's funny to
freeze the world in place when they
particularly in the tech industry where
it's never been frozen where things are
moving constantly even as we speak
there's some young entrepreneur because
we still have some freedom in this
country left not a lot but still some
maybe not any right now but maybe in a
month or so we'll have that freedom back
some young entrepreneur in Silicon
Valley dreaming up a way to crush
Facebook and to call maybe to crush
Amazon
what's a crush in Microsoft and you know
what they are venture capitalists
salivating to give him capital to make
it become real because the beauty of
capitalism is it never stops it never it
never it never it's never static it's
always dynamic and when you free up
economies when you take away the
regulations when you leave people free
beautiful beautiful beautiful things
happen and it's amazing the kind of life
we have today because of capitalism
because we didn't go the socialist route
that you know people a hundred years ago
couldn't even imagine gentlemen we've
said it all and in a way we've we've
only just started the conversation but
it has been a very very interesting hour
plus oh it feels it always feels weird
to stop the conversation somewhere but
at some point every good conversation
must end we've been speaking with Iran
Brooke chairman of the ein Rand
Institute and host of the Iran Brooks
show on YouTube and with Rob Larson
economics professor and author of bit
tyrants and capitalism versus freedom
I've interviewed both of them
extensively you can find those
interviews on my youtube channel and
website gentlemen I really do appreciate
your time today and we must do it again
thank you this was fun we should do it
again this is great I'm sure well